un loisir pour certains une passion pour
d'autres d'accord là dessus la
philatélie la télé s'en amuse depuis des
décennies j'ai découvert une passion
comme maintenant je peux plus séparés
dès 1961 et jusqu'en 1983 les
philatélistes ont droit à leur émission
télé qu'il atterrit ces trente minutes
consacré entièrement au timbre les deux
fois par mois à la présentation de fins
connaisseurs
la journaliste jacqueline cora et
l'industriel lucien berthelot quand vous
touchez les timbres avant de passer
votre collection
lavez vous les mains il faut avoir les
mains très très propre jeudi c'est un
bon ce sont des petits tableaux comme
vous voyez sont très jolies il mérite
qu'on prenne soin d'eux si vous pensez
que la philatélie était réservé aux
adultes
détrompez vous
même les plus jeunes s'y connaissent
écoutez le conseil de ce petit garçon
fidèles collectionneur dans l'âme
c'était en 1973
su chang une maison aucune valeur par
jean pour trouver à atteindre qui l'a
tout petit peu déchiré une manque ni
dans alors là ce fut niveau qu à vous la
perle rare du timbre peut se trouver
n'importe où
mais il ya bien un endroit où les
philatélistes se donnent rendez-vous le
marché au timbre du carré marigny à
paris cette caverne d'ali baba est un
lieu incontournable pour les bonnes
affaires que ce soit pour cette bande 2
en 1977 38 tellement moins trois fois
par semaine
la nature les oiseaux trois fois par
semaine uniquement les jeudis samedis et
l'humain comme pour ce jeune acheteur
toujours en 1977 s'attend pas un peu
ridicule de faire collection de temps au
non non non non c'est d'éteindre ses
c'est passionnant et instructif qu'est
ce que tu comptes faire avec tous ces
timbres
va les garder tu veux revendre les
gardes et puis plus tard les revendre ce
marché existe toujours aujourd'hui
tellement dégoûtant autre place forte
pour les transactions le salon du timbre
dès 2004 il pose ses valises à vincennes
tous les timbres s'y trouvent ou presque
qu'ils soient usés 9 coloré historique
il y en a pour tous les goûts et la
passion reste intacte j'ai commencé
j'avais 8 ans les années 70
vous voyez j'en ai
je pense que je vais dire peut-être
vingt mille trente mille comptes nil est
peut-être un de plus une nouvelle pièce
va pouvoir étoffer la collection de ce
philatélistes en 2021 un timbre à
l'éffigie de valéry giscard d'estaing a
créé un hommage pour commémorer
l'anniversaire de la mort de l'ancien
président
[Musique]